llegó uno de los momentos más esperados
del año para muchos cinéfilos las
nominaciones a los premios Oscar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y Daniel sainnet fue la película que más
sonó en esta gala inicial con un total
de 11 nominaciones entre ellas la mejor
película y mejor director el filme una
historia de ciencia ficción y un
homenaje al amor ha sido una apuesta
diferente que ha logrado colarse en los
premios le Siguen sin novedad en el
frente y el visto de Edward berger y Bad
Luján respectivamente con nueve
nominaciones cada una
entre las candidatas a mejor actriz
destacan la protagonista de la película
favorita y Kate blanchet como directora
de orquesta en tar Ana de armas a fue la
única latina nominada con blog y en la
misma categoría de actores figuran
brendan Fraser por su papel en la
ballena un drama sobre la relación de un
padre obeso y su hija y Paul mezcal por
su interpretación En after Sand un drama
también sobre la relación paterno filial
como actor destaca que yucuana por
Everything everywhere all Thanks que no
para de llevarse premios
[Aplausos]
en la categoría internacional el nombre
más sonado fue el de Argentina 1985
película que narra el juicio de las
juntas militares de la dictadura
Argentina y para Los amantes de la
animación El gato con botas o la versión
de Pinocho de Guillermo del Toro son las
grandes a favoritas los ganadores se
sabrán el 12 de marzo en la gala anual a
más importante del cine
[Música]